all right let's talk about governor
abbott let's talk about government
because this one's about to get really
exciting here
danielle's governor to put it no longer
our governor ours is desantis which i
don't think she's a fan of desantis
either but we'll talk about both of them
okay
so governor abbott announced his plan to
fully
reopen businesses ending state mass
mandate
tax republican governor turns out he's
probably going to next 100 percent
abbott issued an executive order that
resents many of the state's previous
orders allowing all businesses in the
state to fully reopen and revoke in the
statewide
mandate to be clear covet has not
like suddenly disappeared said governor
abbott
responsibly kovitz still exists in texas
the united states and across the globe
but it is clear from the recoveries
the vaccinations from the reduced
hospitalizations
and from the safe practices texans are
using the state mandates
are no longer needed businesses are able
to limit capacity or implement
additional safety protocols
if they choose to which is wonderful
he's leaving it up to you
you know danielle to choose and say we
believe you should wear a mask it's a
choice right
and uh governor newsom quickly responded
to the announcement on tuesday oh
calling it absolutely reckless in a
twitter post newsome has a lean towards
stricter guidelines
in california's pandemic response
danielle what are your thoughts on your
governor
well i think that he was a little upset
with the straw poll at cpac that gave
him a zero percent probability of being
president in 2024
so you think this is because of that oh
yes i think he needed a
he needed a moment he's looking for
headlines oh yeah let me ask you do you
think he wants to run
oh let let's see one two how many times
did he visit
the white house four times when trump
was there
so you think he wants to run i think
every governor
has aspirations especially when it's
this
ninth largest economy on the planet okay
you're saying if you get to that
level where you're the governor you have
to have aspirations
you have such high lofty aspirations you
you could see yourself being president
you're florida's former governor is in
the senate now and okay
let's do this but so you touched up on
one part of the whole thing
so he announces he's opening it up 100
and he leaves it to you business owners
in texas
i'm one in texas i have a big
decent-sized business in texas
i've heard that if we want to open it up
we can open it up if not we don't open
it up right
you say it's because he got zero percent
chance from cpac
running again and that hurt his feelings
so he wanted to get relevant hey here's
what we're doing
uh and all of a sudden media he gets a
few hundred thousand likes on twitter
everyone's talking about it everyone's
saying yes no disagreeing
but how about the actual mandate how
about actually lifting it what are your
thoughts on lifting
and putting it at a hundred percent and
getting people back to work
getting people back to work i think
small business owners that are not able
to get that has
been getting now that's that's that's a
red herring
getting people back to work look at how
you run your company
people individuals in their cubicles
they have their own mandates in terms of
who can get close and who can't
so you run your business responsibly
every business can be open
opening bars at 100 is asinine
it just is you're assuming people are
going to be responsible and they won't
be
look there's a reason that life
expectancy in asia is
longer than it is here in the united
states there's a reason that we didn't
have a flu season
in the united states we were all
protected from one another
so there's something to be said for not
getting sick
there just is look but again
it should be up to
the business owner but you need to have
a responsible governor
you just do it but but i'm sorry daniel
i'm confused so
so you are saying leave it to the small
business owner to decide whether you
were
in public places though sure wear the
mask
okay or you're saying but in public
places
he should say you should wear a mask in
public in public places such
as when i'm out when i'm running when
i'm walking
that then then you're new something
you're like no outdoor dining what an
idiot
okay so you're not new some you're not
abbott what are you what
i'm in between you're not i'm trying to
ensure that people are as responsible as
they should be
did you enjoy dinner last night at louis
boston i did how was it it was great how
where were you sitting at when you ate
the bar how many people were at the bar
tons tons why did you do that
i but we were not all over
each other well you know we're not
people are not all over each other in
texas they have a little bit more
etiquette they'll say hey i'm sorry
wait wait wait wait wait wait people in
texas have more etiquette
uh i think more than florida i don't
know no florida
they're very listen here this is like
people who are like
do you know who i am the etiquette here
is do you know who i am
the etiquette in texas is a little bit
different there's a lot of new yorkers
here so your customer service in florida
is not texas customer service
that's true so so but you enjoyed
yourself last night
i did but i think that there's a certain
amount of
comfort that you get in knowing that
other people have masks on did you send
the tweet thanking desantis
did you say governor desantis thank you
for allowing me to eat at louis bosses
and enjoy this italian food and the
glasses he's also my favorite person
he's somebody here's desantis so
how do you feel about this hashtag
sarcasm hello all right
how do you feel about now desantis on
the other end
you know abbott got zero percent but
desantis on the other end
oh huge okay so mr c yes
so he is a star in a making that
actually has potentially what it takes
to be your president
maybe mine may be his but he could be
our president right
what are your thoughts about desantis
i'm actually curious to know what you're
going to say about desantis
so here we go in the florida panhandle
over the summer
when i came here with my family to
vacation as i do
every year i got away from destin
and the more crowded rosemary's i i took
a step
further beyond that and i only went into
walmart's
because it sounds like my kind of party
because they mandated masks
when he wouldn't in the middle of
a wave of covet
and making teachers go back into the
classroom
when they should have maybe stayed out
for seven days which he
amazingly did it's just
you say that's irresponsible right
totally qualified irresponsible
but he doesn't care okay you you have a
certain appeal
if you appeal to
the rebel to the trump there's a trump
in a lot of people
if you appeal to that person you're
going to make
all kinds of brownie points you're going
to be really
popular at cpac oh i don't think that's
it though i don't think it's just that i
i'm talking pure results is what i'm
talking about
so the unemployment rate in the state of
florida is not any better or worse than
it is in the united states
yeah but it's way better than new york
and california so seriously so go to the
people that were ridiculously
etc etc and what they did they're an
american but here's my here's my
argument for the sentence here's my
argument for the sentence and my
argument for
abbott okay um you know the story about
disneyland disney world this is not a
new story so disneyland you know you
know they
weren't working with bob iger same
company two companies and bob iger's a
democrat newsome wasn't working with him
you know eventually he's like dude i'm
not
going to disney on easter yeah so back
here disneyland shuts down
25 000 employees lose their jobs disney
world's good to go they keep their jobs
so people are able to go feed their
families get the food pay the rent all
that other stuff
same ceo eiger two separate governors
newsom desantis
the census helps disney stay in business
and the employees keep their job
knew some fires 25 i think maybe the
number is even 78 000 people i don't
know the exact number but
it was a big number that lost their jobs
right okay so
let's talk about a sport that would be
qualified as the most
liberal supporting sport in america
which one would you say that is
take the four sports basketball i think
it's fair to say nhl we don't even know
what nhl would be but nhl is
women's sport okay they have more female
fans than any other sport nhl nhl
by far it's not even funny we like to
watch men beat each other yeah
that's right okay so there you go so
what what what sport is the sport that
supports blm liberal and you know
social justice campaign of the year
which is clearly the nba yeah okay
so the nba who would fully
disagree with desantis because of his
irresponsible actions
is here decided to do their playoffs in
florida yeah
the super bowl decided to do their super
bowl
a super bowl in florida the santis is
trying to get
olympics to be in florida why
are people from new york nearly a
trillion dollars of wealth
say over half a trillion dollars of
wealth moving to the most irresponsible
state
florida why are so many californians
leaving to governor abbott state
why if you if you sit there and you
look at it from my perspective the way i
see it he says
responsible make the decision small
business owners
do what you need to do responsibilities
on you let's do the right i have no
problem with that
yeah but i also think you know to to
lift what he did in texas
uh and what desantis did in florida i
think these guys came out being heroes
look what happened in new york every
single day we watched cuomo
every day we were watching cuomo you got
and you know how i feel about cuomo i've
said this many years ago
you're a huge fan but wait a minute i
i've never said i'm not
what i'm trying even until today i think
the guys the two brothers to me there's
an element of it that
i see family i see how their
thanksgiving would be i'm
gonna try to forget politics i'm simply
talking about
they're italians they're italians it's
like hey what's up and their dad mario
you just kind of feel that
you'd want to be at their house at
thanksgiving you know if you your friend
you're like hey cuomo i'm coming over
okay cool come on over families waiting
for you unless you're a young woman
unless you're a young woman yeah unless
you're a young woman okay
so so again you know it started off
cuomo was a hero he's going to be the
next president
newsom is a hero oh he's so responsible
next president
one guy's about to be recalled and the
other guy's about to be impeached
and desantis and abbott look like rock
stars
so kovitt kind of made abbott and
desantis look like
rock stars and the two other governors i
don't know about that
so and you know the irony
the irony is that if you look at the per
capita
death rate in these states they're all
kind of on top of each other
so for all of the overbearing
regulations that were imposed in
california it
didn't save the lives so that's just
that's just me
that you can do you can go too far
that's what i'm saying i don't
i don't mind a mask mandate in public
areas but let
business owners do whatever they need to
do to be in business
well i'm glad i lived in texas and for
five years i'm glad i moved my
headquarters from california to texas
and i'm glad i'm in the state of florida
i cannot tell you how safe i feel
as a business owner as a small business
owner entrepreneur i am glad i'm in
these two states because i have
offices all over california i'm all over
northeast i'm all over dmv
but you can over deregulate that's
what's been happening
with those two states because guess who
was in austin during ice magedon
musk himself he was none too impressed
yeah so you can you can go too far on
either end of the spectrum 2011 sure
there was a super bowl there was ice
everywhere the power grid failed
the power grid ercot in texas said we're
going to fix it
2014 failed again we're really going to
fix it this time
we're going to take those suggestions to
weatherize yeah our power plants
a few years later 2021 people die
and it's a third world experience so you
can go
too far in terms of not having
regulations
i don't disagree it was very
disappointing all i said is how's a
state
this big wasn't prepared for the storm
that they had right how
how's that even possible but at the same
time danielle if we flip it
how does a state like california every
flipping year lose people to fire
and it's not a one-time thing at least
texas this is the worst they've ever had
in a hundred years
how does texas california every year you
got the fire
everything you can't figure it out they
wrote the book on how to not run your
power grid california did
texas had at least had an example to
follow yeah the mudslides
the fires every it's just you have to
want to be there
so really badly because you get the
weather from florida
yeah but you get the taxes from
california who would do that
to be aware who would live in california
with those taxes
quite a lot of people third largest
economy fifth largest accountant the
largest economy in the world i get it i
get it i get it
it's i'm out there once a year but who
would pay those taxes i just don't get
it
when you can live and and so many
companies are agreeing
yeah and that's why on my twitter feed
all the californians when texas was
freezing
there was just the the word is
schadenfreude they were so excited that
there were people suffering in texas
and i'm like are you serious yeah of
course they were nasty
yeah and like you're supposed to be you
know people from the happy state
it's unfortunate that's not america
though but that is a lot of voters on
both sides you know
there's a lot of voters on both sides
that that uh that's why they call it the
left coast
yeah well just a quick point on like why
would you live in california
i'll give a case example we would hear
for years and years and years new
yorkers are considering coming to
florida and like every new year is like
oh the new yorkers are here
you know oh why would you live in new
york why would you live in new york well
you know well you know the taxes
and the weather but it took a freaking
pandemic
and zoom and being able to work from
remote
for people to say like you know what i'm
leaving new york before covet
yeah but not in droves like this no not
india and that's my point with
california is now with zoom
and wfh work from home and work from
anywhere
now you have that luxury whereas
jpmorgan you didn't have that luxury
up for at least 800 000 square feet of
office property
jp morgan's going to have a bigger
footprint employee wise in texas than
it's going to have in new york
800 000 square feet of office space in
new york
pat wants to see states like new york
and california be completely
flipped on its on its head do you know
you need to run you you need a young
rudy giuliani you just do
a young hot roodie you're so funny okay
he was never hot if we just said that he
was good-looking i mean
don't go too far seven or eight that's
all i said it's a seven or eight seven
earnings eight
it's like a five and a half step what
would you say you're you are
what are you adam seven or eight no
you're not seven or eight i
put you as an eight and a half but
you're not you're not i put you
damn can't even get a nine per pound no
no
i'm more obsessed with rudy giuliani
that
you like people people think we're
joking that
he's gonna think about eight and a half
no that's what he's doing people think
that
i'm the one who thought that rudy julian
was hot we had an argument
you were vouching for rudy giuliani i
thought that he's kind of gross one of
the best looking guys i know how about
that one of the best looking guys i know
if i'm one of the best looking guys in
this room you know i know a lot of
good-looking guys yeah you're one of the
best looking guys
okay so so let's let's continue by the
way by the way so so we talked about
texas they did what they did
target toyota gm and macy's in texas
keep wearing masks which is fine do your
thing
employees at gm toyota somebody in texas
will keep their masks on the company
said on tuesday even as the state lifted
okay good
abby's executive order lifted okay got
it we know that relaxing common sense
safety protocols like wearing masks is a
mistake
jason brewer vice president
communication at state affairs of retail
industry leaders association state
said adding that going back on safety
measures will unfairly put retail
employees back in a role
of enforcing guidelines still
recommended by the cdc okay number one
35 of the states puerto rico
as of monday 35 u.s states will along
with district of columbia and puerto
rico mandate the residents wear masks in
public iowa mississippi montana north
dakota
have lifted mass orders earlier
as well so you know you're looking at
this what are the other 11 states that
i've done in montana iowa north dakota
mississippi
georgia florida south carolina georgia
was never even
georgia never even had a mass man yeah
they've never mandated a mask mandate so
again i mean we'll see what's going to
happen the reality of it is every time
these types of decisions are made
every time these types of decisions are
made all the you know one one lady came
out and she said she tweeted she said uh
i just want you to know this is a very
irresponsible decision
i will never i'm a texan i will never le
uh
go anywhere without wearing a mask
matter of fact i'm double masking right
now when i go out so great do it
that's her business she said i hope they
don't force me to take my mask off i
said no one's going to force you to take
my ass
off what are you talking about i said i
said for how many decades have you gone
to the airport and you see folks flying
from asia
and i would always say why they put
their masks on like what happens in asia
you know do they like why do they have
a longer life expectancy yeah so so so
yeah
you think it's because of the mask
versus the food they eat and the how
common peaceful they are and
they have a mediterranean diet but they
also don't have a lot of season like we
do i mean they just
they believe that germs are not for
sharing so but it's just a way of life
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye